continuing our dc fandom cover ridge
today
the suicide squad dc phantom exclusive
sneak
peek so it's not an official trailer i
believe this is a behind the scenes or
featurette something like that
excited to check this out i finally
watched just last week for the first
time batman assault on arkham
uh that is such a good suicide squad
film my god
uh it's amazing let's see what's in
store we we did watch the character roll
call
already just so we're a little bit more
familiar with who the characters are
involved
but we haven't seen this yet so let's
check it out
i think it's going to surprise people
[Music]
there's no one better in the world to
direct the suicide squad
than james gunn i was excited with an
opportunity to be able to do the suicide
squad in the way
it could be done from my point of view
this one is completely unique
this is a gritty 1970s war movie
combined with the brilliance of james
gunn's characters in comedy
you need your director to set goodbye
the suicide squad is just a
twisted fantasy of characters
within each of her character there's a
certain beauty
with the most crappy through and through
be like a douchey captain america the
guy who believes
in peace at any cost no matter how many
people he needs to
kill us on the way okay i got it
don't ever settle back like you think
you know where this is going because
you know as soon as you have some sense
about what's about to happen next
james comes in
[Music]
everyone is exploding janitors heads
arms legs
that's like a big massive graphic novel
brought to life this is gonna be awesome
yeah right wow he's a king shark
what to expect
this has been truly the greatest
most
he's gonna knock it out of the park yeah
dude he's gonna
knock it out of the park like this is
like i feel like you could argue that
guardians is the perfect james gunn
property but i feel like this is like a
step
further just because of the conceit that
they're all these villainous characters
yeah i wish we got a little bit more
hint at some of the comedy because
you know they're saying like yes
combining the character the comedy
sensibilities of james gunn
like ah there's not enough not that much
funny in here
but mostly just bone crunching and
destruction yeah but yeah as we
uh like kind of predicted from you know
the suicide squad logo reveals a lot of
us did that
it has a bit of that dirty dozen vibe to
it and they're saying it's like a 1970s
war film in a way
i love that he's bringing that to life
here and we
listen to some of the interview out of
dc fandom that like
the way we've been doing is we're
listening and then okay okay they're
playing something we want to react
keep an eye on the notifications for
what wb puts it up and he was saying
some things that really stood out to me
especially how they said like oh which
character were you most excited or write
for
and he enlisted harley quinn i don't
know there was something about
the fact that harley quinn's already had
you know birds of prey she was in the
other suicide squad movie uh maybe he's
gonna name one of the more
random ones like peacemaker or something
like that michael rook or
michael rooker's character but he went
with harley quinn
as great as margot robbie already is
just the idea that
james gunn is specifically noted
her for this it's like oh are we going
to get
are we going to get a even newer fresher
take on harley quinn to some extent
because we already got her a great one
in suicide squad a great one in birds of
prey
and now ooh another rendition of her uh
um i
i can't wait to see what he does with
the character well and that made me
really happy too because of you know
the way that birds of prey was received
and the way the previous suicide squad
was
received i like that they seem to be
embracing their returning characters
just as much as hyping the new
characters and yeah something like that
to have her
you know be somebody that he's most
excited about among this whole ragtag
crew yeah i'm glad about that because it
seems like the dceu is being smart to
take the things that do
and did work and carry them forward yeah
you know and adapt them
and for what they're saying here even
with their description of peacemaker of
like he'll do
anything it takes to have pc that means
people left right yeah yeah it seems
like he's actually
really going to embrace the more twisted
diabolical side you know the idea that
you bring all these villains together
for a a hero mash-up he's
really going to embrace that villainous
side of them
oh yeah yeah and i think it's the
benefit of having such a big cast as you
can probably have a couple that are more
easy to identify with and then you'll
have some who are just scumbags through
and through there's so many images in
here that i can't really find right now
we're such on a time crunch
but i believe that like what we saw
there was weasel and
there's that king shark moment damn they
did practical effects for
king shark that looks like it blows my
mind
oh cool i mean i'm sure there'll be cgi
enhancements but
i'm so used to king shark not like i
i love his portrayal on the harley quinn
dc admits
but you know like the the movies in the
animated films and then even on the
flash tv show the last thing i expected
was for them to go practical effects
at all with king shark to see that image
there
really impresses me well that's what i
think that's part of the will be
enhancements
yeah but but if that is indeed like an
animatronic or or makeup or both you
like i think this is partly what these
movies are for is being able to realize
those things with as much
realism as possible and there are some
amazing amazing
creators and fabricators out there who
can make something like that come to
life and i
think back to as much as this wasn't a
well-received movie hansel and gretel
witchhunters has an amazing like
animatronic
puppeteer troll maybe even be the same
performer in there but yeah like to see
both the team that comes together and
just the scope that this is
uh putting out there of you know the
action and the tangibility like it looks
like they really
threw down to make this movie as in
camera as they could
yeah you know it looks really really
cool i always forget how to pronounce
his name flew the board exactly
the board yeah uh james gunn
specifically cited him
too during the interviews i mean he is
hilarious my introduction it was
actually his appearances on conan
o'brien he
is really funny there are some you know
theory theories going around because
suicide squad usually does
something of like they'll kill off
someone early on to really show how
disposable or
expendable any one of these characters
are from the fact of how much they focus
on all these different performers
throughout looks like the team is much
bigger than the last one and that a lot
of them will
probably be killed off throughout yeah
but uh
there were 18 cast members who tuned in
for the pet
panel but uh i think everyone's gonna
have a proper chance to shine i didn't
see any nathan philly in here in the
trailer unless i missed that
much there's like a hint or two there's
like a shot or two of him in here and
there i think but
uh yeah not much showcasing what he's
actually gonna be like
even though harley quinn's in it this
looks like it's
in a different era is there like some
time traveling involved or something
i wouldn't be surprised especially
because i heard there's a character
in here that has the ability to to time
travel someone's from the future
i could be wrong about that i'm kind of
going off a memory here
but i i did hear about that you know i
thought it was just gonna feel akin to
like a 1970s movie yeah yeah
but it actually kind of looks like a
movie in the 70s yeah
yeah actually and with the character
they've chosen and the aesthetic designs
i'm very much under the impression that
it actually
is in the 70s because we still don't
know the details of the plot nope
and again just with the popularity of
time travel and and time travel like
they're opening up their multiverses in
dc specifically like
i would not be at all surprised if they
have some kind of loophole for that
and i can't wait to see it yourself but
for a long time i was under the
impression that idris elba was gonna be
playing uh vigilante but he's playing a
character named bloodsport crazy guns
uses kryptonite bullets and stuff
i believe the follow-up character was a
fanatical racist that's not the version
i think idris alba's playing no
it's gonna be cause he's a villain
all right guys suicide squad are you
really excited for this
what are your thoughts on here which
character are you most excited to see
come to life leave your thoughts down
below
subscribe click that notification bell
last but not least
gene jeter our good friend long time
patronage
follow jean jeter tv on youtube he
recently put out a video
called summertime chill grooves it's a
wonderful playlist some good tunes to
listen to
i gotta thank you personally gene with
umbrella academy taking up so much time
to edit i am
way behind on so many messages right now
all around
the world the world being my phone
emails and patreon messages
so thank you dude for putting this
together because as i've been catching
up and listening to the grooves and it
has been
delightful he does so much other content
on his channel sketches to
some strange trying not to laughs and
other weird challenge videos as well
keep killing it keep putting out great
content during this time of covid
appreciate all the effort you put forth
love you buddy thank you for being you
love eugene i want to cuddle your body
you don't need anything john i want to
you know hear from me it's it's okay you
don't need to
it's hot in here it is i'm going to
murder you and eat your body
to keep cold that's not how that works
[Music]